la toujours des moyens comme ça nous
pister de nous surveiller nos fichiers
nous étudier pouvoir vous situer
n'importe où n'importe quand grâce à
votre téléphone portable
ce procédé a un nom la géolocalisation
au début des années 2000 elle arrive en
france avec la démocratisation de la
téléphonie mobile
ça vous permet de savoir exactement où
vous vous trouvez à un endroit pour
pouvoir ensuite vous déplacez vous
reprendre par exemple à un rendez vous
la géolocalisation
une innovation qui pose très vite un
problème celui de l'atteinte aux
libertés individuelles 2006 première
alerte en france une société privée
propose aux parents de suivre à la trace
leurs enfants grâce à l'opérateur orange
cela peut ressembler à de l'espionnage
le service est payant 4 euros pour 5
localisation même si l'accord des
enfants est indispensable le service est
mal perçu du côté des plus jeunes
par exemple quand la bise pour éviter
les dérives de la géolocalisation un
organisme la cnil la commission
nationale de l'informatique et des
libertés est chargée de protéger les
données des français à qui s'adresse
cette commission à tout le monde à toute
personne qui pense avoir été victime
d'abus des abus qui sont aujourd'hui
essentiellement liées au développement
de l'informatique
c'est à lui soit le cours but les a
dénoncés en 2011 il est l'un des
premiers lanceurs d'alert sur les
dangers de la géolocalisation pour le
courbis est un utilisateur d'iphone
comme les autres ou pas tout à fait car
il est aussi informaticien de métier
après avoir fouillé son téléphone il
tombe sur des données très personnelles
des données stockés automatiquement à
l'insu des utilisateurs
la période recouvre du 5 avril au 21
avril
et on voit que je suis parti dans le sud
de la france suite à cette affaire la
cnil enquête
selon elle il n'y a pas eu de traçage
seulement des données conservées sans
l'accord de paul courbis
depuis la loi informatique et liberté de
1978 les entreprises dans l'obligation
de demander votre consentement avant de
géolocaliser
les seules personnes autorisées avec géo
localiser sans votre approbation
ce sont les policiers notamment dans le
cadre d'enquêtés de filature virtuel la
géolocalisation donne avec précision la
latitude et la longitude d'un objet
grâce à une balise qui émet un signal
capté par satellite à souk all vip 19
le gouvernement envisage de lancer une
application de traçage grâce au
bluetooth et uniquement sur la base du
volontariat
vous pourrez savoir si vous avez été en
contact avec une personne infectée
[Musique]